hey what's up my name's Sam leach I'm a
property investor and in this video I'm
gonna be talking about tax how you can
save tax through using the strategy
service accommodation which is a
fantastic property investment strategy
I've been investing in property now for
over a decade I've trained tens of
thousands of people in property and I've
also written a best-selling book by tho
rent hide serviced accommodation has
seemed to shock the government and
they're saying why is everyone doing it
why is 7% of houses in Greater London
used for serviced accommodation people
are making a lot of money through
serviced accommodation and the reason is
is because the government absolutely
crippled landlords with stupid tax rules
they upped stamp duty and they see
before if you bought a house that was
less than 125,000 pounds you didn't have
to face them GT that was great I used to
buy all my houses less than 125 grand
never paid stamp duty they dropped it to
40 thousand pound there's no houses less
than 40,000 pounds and if they are less
than 40 thousand pounds they were
mortgageable because they're so cheap
anyway so that means that you've got to
pay stamp duty every time you buy a
bides in the house but don't worry Stan
G's not a lot of money it's only 3% so
you buy a house for a hundred grand and
you pay three thousand pounds for what
just to the government for being there
so that's one annoying thing next 2016
they announced they were going to bring
in section 24 I was crossing my fingers
hoping they wouldn't bring it in they
said that they were gonna face it in and
it was gonna properly come in in 2020
guess what it's now 2020 and they
brought it in another horrible stupid
tax law section 24 says that you cannot
claim your mortgage payments as tax
deductable so if you're renting a house
out for five hundred pounds your
mortgage just three hundred pounds your
profits two hundred right no best thing
you've got to pay tax on the whole five
hundred that's never happened in any
business in the whole of history ever
before government what is your problem
why are you so auntie
Lord's next you making a little bit of
money through property isn't it great
and then you've your boiler breaks and
then you've got expenses and it's
annoying let me talk about serviced
accommodation service combination
firstly if you buy a property and you're
buying it for service denomination
purposes if you don't know what serviced
accommodation is I suggest that you
check out one of my other videos where I
talk about what it is and how you can do
it but you don't pay stamp duty unless
it's one hundred and fifty thousand
pounds or more you paid zero w isn't it
fantastic you be and how it works is
when you buy a property if it's going to
be serviced accommodation it's as if
it's a commercial property so you'll pay
commercial tax which is much much less
so that's the first amazing advantage no
more three thousand pounds for buying a
hundred gram house to the government
good next section 24 this stupid law
that says that you have to pay your
mortgage payments are not tax deductible
section 24 doesn't apply if you're
renting the property out as a serviced
accommodation property so if you're
renting out on short stays and you climb
back your mortgage payment as tax
deductible which is fantastic so
everyone was moaning about 6 of 24
doesn't apply and that's why so many
landlords have converted their
properties from by Siletz to serviced
accommodation to HMOs to serviced
accommodation and the only are they
saving loads of money on tax but they're
also realizing but they're getting way
more rent so that's the next thing
lastly capital allowances with a
serviced accommodation property do you
get a new boiler guess what happens you
climb it as an expense as long as you
are renewing replacing or repairing
anything in the house
it is completely tax deductible with
capital allowances now listen I am NOT a
tax expert I am not qualified to give
tax advice but this is what I will say
number one challenge your accountant on
everything don't let your accountant
tell you that you need to pay tax if you
don't think you do you've got to
challenge it I've had situations where
I've been buying houses and my
solicitors and my accountants I said you
need to pay this mint stamp Julia
oh I read on the HMI website and they're
all we're not sure and I've challenged
it and then they've looked in between us
it actually Samuel you are right so even
though I'm not qualified to give tax
advice I challenge my accountants and
you should do the same number to
consider serviced accommodation as a
strategy if you're a higher at taxpayer
or even if you're not even if you're
just getting started
consider it as a strategy because the
cash flow is great and the tax benefits
are even better and then number three is
research study and educate yourself do
not just take the easy road do not just
do what people tell you to do if you
just do what's expected and what people
tell you to do they're gonna end up
going to school getting good grades go
into uni getting a half-decent job
buying a house paying off the mortgage
retiring at 67 and then dying don't just
do the status quo what the government
what the education system what everybody
expects you to do challenge everything
think outside the box live better be
better make more give more so that's my
advice to you today I hope you find it
useful please do smash the like button
if you enjoyed this video also subscribe
turn the notification bow on and I need
this message to get to more landlords
and to get to more investors so to help
with the YouTube algorithm so this
YouTube video pops up everywhere please
do me a favor and comment below
it really helps make this video more
popular and get the message out there
thanks for watching see you next time
peace out
[Music]